nächste woche lernen sie dann noch
schreiben und das schöne senkel binden
dann sind sie endgültig einsatzbereit
das war's wegtreten ok danke capos so
meine lieben freunde danke an alle die
es so zahlreichen die kommentare
geschrieben haben allerdings muss ich
euch enttäuschen keiner von euch ist der
glorreiche gewinner der mit zeigen
konnte wie der himmel ist irgendwie
komisch
oh mein gott das ist irgendwo ich bin
zurzeit mit den schildern an rum amrumer
oder um ganz immer noch mit den
schildern amrum spielen von daher ist
das sind komisch was ich hier ich
irgendwas falsch eingestellt das darf
eigentlich nicht so gut ist gut es geht
die party erst mal hallo und zurück
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
neuen folge drohnen befreiungs einheit
das depot holen
ich bin das gerade direkt nach der
letzten folge auf und zwar habe ich das
gesehen als ich 18 und ich bin so blöd
bin ich sogar unter gesprungen und habe
das nicht gesehen hier
und naja hier brands also hier geht es
dann auf jeden fall weiterhin wir können
erst mal nachmachen
unsere hinten in panel vor allem
übrigens renner ich gerade nebenbei die
asian games die schon längst hochgeladen
wurden wenn ihr dieses video gerade seht
und ich lade gerade ein video hoch und
zwar ist das golem links oder das feuer
brennt das sehr cool
müsste nicht verstehen nur dass das ein
bisschen haken könnte eventuell hier war
mal ein büro jetzt ist hier alles
geschmolzen
in case of emergency
so war da unten jetzt aber ich will mir
hätten doch einfach so rüber springen
verstehe ich jetzt nicht was ist da
kleine öffnung also irgendwie deshalb
haben wir total unsinnig oder warum ist
er überhaupt lava wenn man das doch weg
machen kann
wieso kann ich da nicht drüber springen
und hessen am was soll das
ich möchte mit ihnen das machen -
parieren naja
so da hinten auf jeden fall die kleine
öffnung nicht mal sagen müssen
tausendprozentig darüber ob
die deckenhöhe bereitet mir ein bisschen
sorgen aber das sollte alles hat
geklappt schalter wird gedrückt
laufen der helium mich ob es in sehr
kurzer fahrt abteilung zur kontrolle des
hebel zum öffnen der tür mit korridor wo
ein skelett ist ein knopf endlich mal
ein bisschen beleuchtung hier so die tür
ist nix drin das ist natürlich sehr
schön hier seine crew aber jemand
passiert nichts stehe ich nicht oft so
wird korridor lager sehr kleines lager
naja wir laufen einfach weiter zum
korridor also korridor was solche war da
schon dran müssen jetzt wieder hier hoch
oder wie wollte jetzt bin ich doch im
korridor diva stand auf dem schild
klingen wie total verwirrt
mir fällt gerade auf das ich ja dann
nochmal job muss relativ egal welcher
zeit ja mal ein büro jetzt ist er ist
geschmolzen war geschlossen hier brennt
brand haben wir doch gelöscht
verdammt was mich hier das
verschlechtert hat unnötig dass ich hier
den ganzen weg wieder zurück bin
egal aber da wer solche jump skills sind
nicht schaffen das natürlich alles ganz
schnell nicht anelka was reden wir den
korridor so jetzt bin ich dann im
korridor und was bringt mir das dann
wenn bach das wird jetzt geöffnet hier
ada
es besteht ja auch alles gut gemacht die
agency können von sich behaupten die
ausbildung bestanden und obendrein die
firma vor einer großbrand vor einem vor
einem großbrand heißes bewahrt zu werden
sie dürfen nun zur urkundenübergabe in
den bürokraten trakt wenn du das lesen
kannst kannst du das lesen
danke danke danke für diese offenbarung
büroklammer büroklammer trakt kakerlaken
trakt
ok go selbst laufen wir jemals ein
bisschen jetzt auch schon mal probiert
euch mit pfeil selbst abzuschießen in
denen so nach oben schießt geht das
überhaupt
sehr klug wie ich euch das zeigen wollte
daran sieht man wieder was für eine
intelligenzbestie ich doch bin mit
bürokraten trakt so jetzt meine kiste
glückwunsch hervorragende arbeit agent
wir nehmen auf dem klo um unerledigte
geschäfte zu tätigen
auf dem klo währenddessen können sie ja
mal schauen wie hoch ist coesfeld das
war's nächste woche lernen sie dann noch
schreiben und das schöne senkel binden
dann sind sie endgültig einsatzbereit
das war's wegtreten ok danke backbord
das also gerade unser lieber typ ia das
uns rennert es mit dem 30 m 35 smaragde
mister ober bürokrat montgomery buch
nicht pompös es ist montgomery buch da
maximal das go ein und 41 wer fakten
ich hab doch nur was da eigentlich soll
das ist dieses komische ding ich habe
doch nur 35
ich habe sechs verpasst naja
ich würde sagen das war's also wenn da
auch schon steht maximal ascot die man
erreichen konnte insgesamt und wenn buch
wird auch drin steht das war's dann war
das eine sehr kurze folge von ihnen die
fünf minuten oder so ich weiß gar nicht
wie weit weg sind kann ich das nicht
werfen kann ich nicht das ist unser
inventar das sind alles sachen die wir
noch übrig haben sehr cool
sehr cool muss schlagen aber wir haben
noch wer sehr viele sachen und naja also
web download link es in der beschreibung
nicht bewährte bewertet diese bewährte
die magnum erleben und zwar würde ich
der map als note eins geben keine
einsplus weil dort rechtschreibfehler
transit und so ein paar sachen die sind
einfach nicht eindeutig obwohl okay das
mit dem court das war schon mein fehler
naja jedenfalls möchte ich mich bei euch
fürs zuschauern bedanken
viele meinten das sei ihr
lieblingsprojekt bisher von mir gewesen
weil es einfach die map hatten effekt zu
mir gepasst meldet ihr dass ich doch
teilweise echt herzhaft darüber
geschmunzelt habe muss ich auch ganz
offen zuzugeben
und ja ich wollte mich einfach bei euch
bedanken für die ganzen positiven bewerb
positiven bewertungen und ja wie schon
gesagt danke an die ganzen daumen hoch
daumen runter kommentare und so weiter
hilft mir mal wieder weiter clark
allgemein dass ihr hier seid ihr seit
mittlerweile ein großer bestand in
meinem leben geworden jetzt ohne scheiß
das ist schon heftig wenn man nach hause
kommt in der 70.000 leute und die
fahrten auf einem video von einem ist
das schon krass
naja da fällt mir doch glatt eine träne
was augen nicht also wenn ihr euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
positive bewertung freuen
schaffen wir 1000 stellen wir das so
vielen letzten partner ich hatte die
ganze zeit wieder hin und her lamentiert
ganz viele das sei total bescheuert dass
ich die ganze zeit hin und her hüpfen
deswegen lasse ich das jetzt einfach mal
und die hält künftig hin und her dass
mein gott das bin ich halt ich wieder
hin und her das bringt mich irgendwie
zur vernunft ich dann etwas sagen will
ich am liebsten oder das ansehen der
bürokraten tag wird ihnen präsentiert
von paketen mit so von autos pays de
cati kitty yo
soweit ich suche mir ganz kurz ich habe
husten nicht darf das also war ich lass
uns mal lieber dann kann ja die schilder
reinpacken damit dass ich so ein
bisschen schöner aussieht bis hin zu
hell
so also meine damen und herren das war
die was anlass dafür kommt im kreis das
war die map wie schon gesagt 1
eigentlich sogar noch bessere hilfe das
schrecklich sowas hatte ich dann zum
beispiel damit bestehe aber wenn ich
dann endlich mal neue pc ab dann
wäre ich das definitiv anders lösen also
dann wäre ich die shader richtig
bearbeiten jetzt haben wir das problem
ist die mich richtig angezeigt wird und
man sieht da hin dass sie unten wirklich
alles ausgerichtet anbieter und export
naja das hier war die map eine sehr sehr
geile map muss ich sagen jetzt habe ich
das ja alles wieder beliebte doch dann
mache ich die map jetzt mal wieder hier
dass sie irgendwie existiert das können
zu welchen dauern weil ich muss noch ein
paar sammlers machen also ich fliege
jetzt mal so ein bisschen rum und dann
will ich sagen wenn jeden fall danke
dass ihr die ganze zeit aufbewahrt und
danke allgemein für alles wir sehen uns
dann irgendwann wieder wenn ich mich
jetzt irgendwie vom stuhl fall und
mittlerweile knochen brechen sterben so
was dann sehen uns wieder auch nur dann
ich quatsche schon wieder ich glaube die
verabschiedung ist bisher wirklich
länger als das komplette video bisher
naja egal wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal tschüss